I'm a debride I'm a reporter now I  always seem to find myself questioning  something the government may not be  looking at I found something really bad  taking  look around in the world who do you see  a planet on the brink of collapse human  games are disposable but man and  symbiote combined this is a new race  your species a higher life-form  what do you want me  [Applause]  we cannot just hurt people  we have a deal I like so many thankful  time  to that power it's not completely awful  you have no idea how much you're scaring  me right now a walk away  and you just might survive guys you do  not want to do this trust me  we'll always come at a cost  bleep you on and then both her legs and  everybody to face light up your head you  will be this almost weightless fit with  pink with you going down the street  [Music]  oh I have a parasite yeah name is Jen  [Applause]  you